[Music]
from the 1940s into the 1970s pinball
was banned in many major US cities not
too many people realize it actually came
over from the Renaissance the original
game was called Bagatelle and a known
gangster from Chicago brought it over
here added the pins in the metal balls
hence the name pinball even though we
use very few pins and pin balls these
days for some reason the named is stuck
it goes back as early as 1931 is
arguably the first year of pinball so
this is 1933 Chicago's World Fair this
was truly a game of chance and this is
one of the reasons that pinball became
illegal in the United States for well
over 30 years on July 1st 1971 New
Orleans District Attorney Jim Garrison
was arrested for accepting bribes of up
to 1500 a month to protect illegal
gambling in the city nine other men were
also arrested facing seventy thousand
dollars in fines and a possible five
year sentence for helping to transport
the pinball machines
two of the men arrested were policemen
you're talking pre-world War two right
after the Great Depression and they had
just legalized alcohol so now they have
to have something that's got to be evil
and pinball seem to be being did in
Hartford Connecticut in 1959 the state
police conducted a raid that involved
the arrest of 35 people and the
confiscation of 44 pinball machines
those arrested faced a $500 fine a year
in jail or possibly both you see that
the flippers are backwards to what we
know today this one here if it was sold
here in the United States it was housed
illegally who's played illegally not
only was it subject to confiscation but
the owner of the Machine was subject to
jail time on August 6 1942 Adid was
arrested for operating a pinball machine
outside of his delicatessen during his
trial pinball machines were brought in
to prove that it was gambling however
the jury enjoyed playing pinball and did
not view it as gambling they're saying
it's a game of chance you're gambling
because you can win free games on these
machines in 1948 a cigar store owner was
arrested for owning a pinball machine
after an undercover patrol man
game the owner was arrested for unlawful
possession of a gambling machine and if
you look at the artwork
it was totally designed for men or men
you want to talk about a sexist they
look at the artwork on pinball
especially in the early years that's
racy for today these were all in men's
establishments women were not allowed in
Honolulu July 1959 22 people were
arrested for permitting gambling on
pinball's the flippers that we know
today in nineteen I believe it's 1953 as
a cost cutter they took out the six
flippers took him to the bottom and said
well at least it covers the entire play
field inadvertently turning it into a
game of skill and that's the leg that
Roger Sharpe took and stood on as he
fought it all the way to the Supreme
Court so that's when pinball started
becoming legalized again Sharpe proved
to the City Council that pinball was a
game of skill by calling his own proper
shot and making it
[Music]
[Applause]